Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This paper is about designing and creating
furniture with pieces that are geometrically
interlocked.
Such pieces not only have artistic value,
but such structures can also enhance the integrity
and sturdiness of a piece of furniture.
This piece of work takes a simple 2D drawing
of this interlocking structure and assembles
the required pieces for us to build a 3D model
from them.
This drawing can be done with one of the most
user friendly modeler program out there, Google
SketchUp.
This can be used even by novices.
From these disassembled parts, it is highly
non-trivial to create a 3D printable model.
For instance, it is required that these pieces
can be put together with one translational
motion.
Basically, all we need is one nudge to put
two of these pieces together.
If you ever had a new really simple piece
of furniture from Ikea, had a look at the
final product at the shop, and thought, "well,
I only have 10 minutes to put this thing together,
but anyway, how hard can it be"?
And you know, 3 hours of cursing later, the
damn thing is still not completely assembled.
If you had any of those experiences before,
this one push assembly condition is for you.
And the algorithm automatically finds a sequence
of motions that assembles our target 3D shape,
and because we only have 2D information from
the input, it also has to decide how and where
to extrude, thicken, or subtract from these
volumes.
The search space of possible motions is immense,
and we have to take into consideration that
we don't even know if there is a possible
solution for this puzzle at all!
If this the case, the algorithm finds out
and proposes changes to the model that make
the construction feasible.
And if this wasn't enough, we can also put
this digital furniture model into a virtual
world where gravitational forces are simulated
to see how stable the final result is.
Here, the proposed yellow regions indicate
that the stability of this table could be
improved via small modifications.
It is remarkable to see that a novice user
who has never done a minute of 3D modeling
can create such a beautiful and resilient
piece of furniture.
Really, really nice work.
Loving it.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!